maintenant il y a des gens qui se
couvrent le visage parce qu'ils mettent
feu à des poubelles et des choses comme
ça il y a une montée de la violence ça
fait quatre ans qu'on le dit qu'il va
avoir une montée de la violence
aujourd'hui le gouvernement tout le
tissu démocratique il n'a pas respecté
il n'a pas respecté par aucun moyen et
quand il a vu qu'il allait perdre il a
passé un 49-3 tous ces citoyens
aujourd'hui bah ils ont un problème
c'est que même quand il passe par le
tissu démocratique ils sont pas écoutés
alors comment ils font alors on voit
démonter de la violence qui va monter
crescendo on oublie de dire qu'il y a
SDF qui s'est fait massacrer hier on
oublie de dire que la brave aime a
écrasé les jambes d'un citoyen qui était
à terre alors qu'il a bien vu qu'ils
étaient là on fait pas voir les images
aujourd'hui des gens qui étaient
totalement pacifistes qui se sont fait
exploser la gueule donc malheureusement
oui la violence c'est triste hein mais
elle va monter des deux côtés et si le
gouvernement des amorce pas tout ça ça
va être ça va être terrible on va finir
par avoir des morts mais ce gouvernement
fait la source d'oreille je rappelle à
tout le monde que pendant le discours
d'Emmanuel Macron il a quand même osé
dire hier imaginez-vous hein les
smicards n'ont jamais eu autant de
pouvoir d'achat mais c'est une honte
totale d'entendre ça